[Music]
shhh
she's got a good aim
what are we doing today aunt we are
barbecuing
and celebrating just i don't know what
we're celebrating we're just having some
good family july 4th
that's true well it's tomorrow but yeah
i was just being able to swim with you
guys
isaac's been wanting to swim for a long
time and
ava's second time swimming here and our
kids just need some more friends you
know i love it when you guys come over
take advantage of your pool yeah because
you don't have a pool bringing up by the
pool
yeah chilling relaxing chilling relaxing
long weekend
long weekend all right well you're on
summer break so it doesn't even feel
like a
long weekend to you huh just a humongous
weekend yeah you're lucky
i wish i could be on summer break too
[Music]
i got you we got
shrimp ribeye steak veggies
hey that looks good you know how to do
it big
[Music]
what are you doing tiffany
[Music]
how charred that looks and it's gonna be
so juicy inside
[Music]
the chicken one the one that i didn't
make i'm sorry
[Music]
let's go isaac
[Music]
oh that was it wait i just turned on my
[Laughter]
phone
yeah you like it
you had no idea how close you were
[Music]
what happened what happened whoa
i hate that one the spinning one chased
me when i was little
it got in my eye burnt all my eyelashes
that's where you are
oh no give me a
[Music]
he kiss it
all right so we're at the rose bowl rose
bowl yeah with my brothers
there's remy adrian christian
and we came to see the fireworks show
the firework show was beautiful
they're beautiful worth the price of
admission what would happen to you
uh well i had quite the adventure prior
to watching the fireworks show
so what he would happen here is that he
didn't want to pay the 10
to pay for a clear bag and have them
switch out
his actual camera bag because he brought
a camera then
he decided to go all the way back
to the car which we parked like 30
million miles away it's super freaking
far where we parked so he ended up
running back we're not even running
walking really fast to go back to the
car
to put the camera away he ended up
finally making it back
actually he made it back on time which
was insane because
it was like right in the nick of time
but then by the time he's about to sit
down
in our row the guy at the the front of
the like the very beginning of the row
he had a crazy attitude because he was
drunk
he wouldn't get up for casey to come
into the row
and then casey's like why you're too
tired to stand up and then the guy
started getting in space
pretty much he was trying to start some
problems but then casey remained calm
right yep i tried to be the bigger man
and walked away had my hands up and
walked away
yeah now as we're leaving though so it's
a circle right the same
circle yes and we walk in the direction
that is closest to
the car obviously any sane person would
do that
we walk like a good ten minutes in one
direction before someone says
hey you can't go any further this part's
closed off walk back around the other
way we're like our car's like
right there like we could totally see
your car if you tried
and they said nope you gotta walk around
the other way so we're now walking
around the entire building
but anyway it was really funny it's
actually
really like i don't know if the word is
irony like ironic
but we had a lot of bad luck moments but
it's even all be worth it because the
fireworks show is really beautiful
it's fun it's memorable i'll remember
this night forever
yeah the night i paid 100 bucks to go
work out
oh yeah because it's a lot of walking i
mean isaac's going to be glad to find
out if he missed out on all this because
isaac is actually spending the day with
his dad
all right but maybe next year now we
know what to do now we know
if you want to come to the rose bowl if
you want to go to the rose bowl and
watch the fireworks
don't pay for the actual tickets inside
what you should do
is just pay for the parking bring your
whole picnic set up just have a nice
like
family cookout in the parking the
parking lot here is on the golf course
so you're pretty much on grass
so you can just relax on the grass still
get to see the beautiful fireworks show
not have to deal with the whole angry
guys by the row that's preventing you
from setting your seat
also the way we were sitting we had to
like turn our neck
and like look up cranking our neck yeah
just like this the entire time
kind of funny but it was really
beautiful though like seeing fireworks
like that
being right in front of your face it was
awesome that was like the closest i've
ever been to fireworks ever
but anyway if you want to just avoid the
mess just
bring a blanket relax on the grass
pay for the parking ticket and you'll be
set
so today's a new day fourth of july was
last week
but before we finish this video i did
want to address something that you guys
have been
asking me about for quite some time now
and i've been
putting it off but i feel now it's a
pretty good time to talk about it um but
yeah a lot of you guys have been
sending me messages commenting
when will i be back to jk news
well the unfortunate
reality is that i will no longer be
coming back to jk news
this wasn't my decision but it was
brought to my attention that i no longer
fit in well with the show
and i had to agree with them because
honestly i
have been feeling this way for some time
now and i've
just stuck it out for these past couple
years that i've been feeling this way
because
i have felt an undying loyalty
and love for this company so that's why
i've just been
trying to do my best while being in this
position
of hosting and being cast in jk news i
will always always hold a ton of love
for that company and the people that
allowed me to
be part of that company so i started
working for them back in
2012 and back then i started off as
like casey's girlfriend just coming
around and helping on set
whatever time i could spare because at
the same time i was working at the
hospital
i did that for a whole year and then
after a year
i was given the opportunity to be an
intern and so
i took the opportunity i was very
grateful for that and so i
interned for a whole nother year after
that year of internship that's when i
was officially brought on to the company
and added to their payroll
which i was so grateful for because at
that point it allowed me to leave the
hospital so i didn't have to juggle
jk and the hospital anymore and at that
same time that's when joe bart and david
took me on as their assistant to earn as
much as i was
like to with jk's pay and then with
assisting i was able to earn as much as
i was earning
back at the hospital where i was so
freaking grateful i was like
so so so thankful that they were able to
help me like that because i didn't have
to do that
and so they helped me in a time where i
really needed it from then on like
my roles just evolved within the company
i no longer assisted
the three of them anymore but it was a
kickstart into
me being able to have this life with jk
and having
the independence away from working at
the hospital which is what i really
wanted so i was so grateful to them for
allowing me that opportunity and so
those of you that have been following us
for this long you guys know
what happened after that which is that
we became family the friendships became
so strong
that i really thought that nothing could
ever change that but
you know life happens and people grow
people change situations change
and so over time i started to feel kind
of like my place in jk news
was disjointed like i kind of felt
that i was given a role to play but
i was given like inconsistent
instructions on how to play that role
so it was really confusing but i tried
my best to do
my best and that's kind of like how i've
been
i've been with jk news in terms of
hosting and i also realized as i got
older
like my sense of humor changed because
if you guys know that show
you know it has a very particular type
of sense of humor
um and also like my own personal like
thought process and the things that i
believed in were really different from
everyone else in that room
which is fine like everyone has you know
their everyone's entitled to their own
experiences and their own thoughts and
all that and so i was just
trying to do the best i could in the
role that i was given
ultimately like i said i was just really
trying to stick it through because i
really really love that company and i
felt
like just always been feeling really
loyal to that company so
that's why i stuck around even though i
started feeling like oh
i don't think i really have a place here
anymore but let's just
see because you know they need me they
need a host so
i'll do what i can as long as i can but
yeah the most
unfortunate thing about this whole
situation was how
it went down let me take you back to
april
so back in april uh two days before we
were supposed to shoot i was notified
that i was no longer going to be on the
roster
and so after finding that out i then
requested
like can i have my schedule a month in
advance just like any other job
usually you have your schedule a month
in advance but jk doesn't work like this
we tend to find out the week of
which day specifically we're going to be
filming so
after you know like finding out that i'm
no longer going to be there for that day
which by the way we don't get paid
salary we get paid day right so
you know it affected the pocket so i'm
like hey can i just have my schedule a
month in advance just to better manage
my expectations and my schedule
but then that led to a very unfortunate
conversation with one of the owners to
the point where
he took me off the schedule completely
and so the next day
after i was taken off the schedule i
ended up having a medical emergency
and also at that time um like the next
day after i found out
that my grandma was really sick and so
i ended up flying out to mexico to be
with her
and so i just took a few like a couple
weeks to just
you know like collect myself and deal
with my personal problems
and then after a couple weeks i then
fell well enough to
contact this said owner to try to
work things out with him and see if i
can you know like
just let's watch what we had and let's
just get back to work
but then he had me wait
three weeks before we can have that
conversation
so it was already three weeks of me
taking time for myself
i reach out to him he tells me i can't
talk to you for another three weeks
when we finally speak after all that
time
i was given the impression that we had
resolved everything
that we had uh gone to a place a really
good place where
i could now be put back onto the
schedule and get back to work and
everything's
great but then i get a text afterwards
saying that both owners wanted to speak
with me
but that ended up being the week that i
was in dallas so then we had to push
our meeting till the following week so
now at this point
it's two months since i've been barred
from
coming in to shoot and once we finally
have this meeting with the three of us
i was then told that there isn't a
future
with jk muse with me in it anymore and
um and that time that i had been away
had allowed the guys to have a really
good time on set which i was honestly
really relieved to hear that
because like i said i've been feeling
myself out of place on that set for
a couple years now and so um finding out
that they were having such a great time
was i was really happy for them because
i i really truly care about the show and
if that's going to make a better show
without me in it then i was
perfectly okay with that i completely
agreed with them that i did not
see myself fitting in really well with
that show and so that's pretty much how
we left that meeting
but to be honest i was i was quite sad
and honestly really disappointed that
that was
the route that they decided to take with
me you know ice me out for two months
just to get the boot at the end i mean
that was pretty disrespectful in my
opinion but
it's just my opinion um but it's totally
okay
i am really happy that they
are having a better show without me
being part of it
i i feel a sense of relief that i don't
have to
have that responsibility in that room
anymore to
play that very confusing role um
and honestly i'm just so grateful that i
even had the opportunity to begin with
to
to even work with this company for
almost a decade
so i am just so grateful for all the
love
all the opportunities all the
experiences that i got to to have with
jk and i am
just really happy that i i was even
blessed with those experiences to begin
with so yeah that's pretty much what
happened you guys i know you guys have
been wondering
for quite some time now but i felt like
you know what let's just
get it out there you guys can know we
can close this chapter and move
move forward you guys always know that
you can still catch up with me here on
tiffin case and also on big mood
so um yeah there's just a lot of
exciting things happening in the future
you know there's
there's always going to be chapters that
close in your life and then you move
forward
and that's pretty much what kind of
happened here
um but yeah i'm i'm really thankful to
even have
had the opportunity to get to know you
guys
thanks to jk i'm so grateful to them for
that
and yeah just that's what happened
so anyway thanks for listening i will
see you guys in the next video
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]